before you punch me there is something
you should know this woman that we're
fighting over is not ordinary woman no
you don't know how could you had it if
I'm going to die I want the whole world
to know how great she is why do you want
me to shut up you afraid you afraid I'll
say something that will help you you're
that sensitive you're going to cry softy
then listen punch me all you want when
I'm done beat me to a pole but let me
say how I feel for her do this one thing
for her she is worth it do you know
about send ever tea we're too big for
you maybe I should use one or two
syllables while speaking to you sir when
did Betty means a happy accident or
pleasant surprise a fortunate mistake
specifically the accident of finding
something good while not specifically
searching for it that's what our love
was a happy egg see dense we did not
plan on this she is amazing she is so
very good she has made me happier that I
thought was possible before huh it was
like I was living a black and white and
suddenly she brought color to my world
and by some miracles she chose me she
was the princess to my pauper the Batman
try Robin the Picard to my West
and crusher she was so much better and I
was so unworthy but yet she wants me by
some miracle stroke of luck she wants me
and her kisses last me until death which
might not be that far off yes we're
talking about the same woman you idiots
and now you can punch me